[Music]
how you guys doing i'm in detroit at the
myth that institute let's go ahead and
take a look inside and get a sneak peek
before the main event begins
zakaria yeah what can you tell us about
mifta
subhanallah you know we're very blessed
to have a place like
here in michigan
uh you know they have always you know
events conferences seminars bringing
these amazing speakers from you know all
around the world
it really you know creates an
environment where
people really want to learn about islam
and benefit anything you know a range of
different topics
so alhamdulillah we have a service like
here in michigan mashallah all right
what the brother just told me see when
they bought the facility
actually it was facing towards the qibla
look we got our little qibla app and
it's facing
towards the qibla alhamdulillah is that
nice
you got the whole this is the whole myth
crew here
yeah
amazing like it's huge
this is
because
there's nothing like this in chicago for
the muslims not this big
harass coffee
in the house also alhamdulillah the
brothers gave us a little bit of a nice
tour here at mifda so it was nice
meeting all of you thank you guys for
coming first and nice meeting you you
know we always see you on youtube and
stuff but thank you guys for coming to
love that you guys
for uh coming it's a pleasure to meet
you all
of course
that's the beautiful thing about islam
and islam just means to submit your will
to that one creator one guy that one god
and that's the name
you know when malcolm
when when muhammad ali when they went
back to their roots and they went back
and they started digging they came to
islam because they saw what you're
talking about that all the prophets
remember this
the
when malcolm went yeah to
mecca right yes yes yes
yeah it messed his head up right because
he never
seen someone yell colored
or this man color that's feminine or
that man colored
that all got along exactly that's
different races where it lets you know
at the end of the day god is love
love is peace
and when people can understand that
that's when this world will get better
where you can show your kids
how much do you love how much do you
know about islam have you liked looking
into malcolm
i have i have read
every bible
have you read the quran
yes yeah yeah what was the main message
you got from it
just like the holy bible the whole thing
is
everything is love do you believe jesus
was god or sent by god because we says
we believe he's a mighty messenger and
we love i believe that jesus
which is god's son
how can i say this in the correct way
he's another prophet and what i mean by
another prophet
there's no one higher than
the lord you feel me that's the almighty
the creator that happens on earth is
that that's the one all praise and
things and worship belong to the
creators but yes you know his son
was a a prophet to show everybody
something now when you say son what we
would just say we would just make an
adjustment we would say obviously he's
closer to god than any of us
metaphorically would say that we're all
the children of god but god doesn't have
sons and daughters you know literally
that's right right right right and i
agree with that there you go mind if i
if i just take one minute i'll give you
a real quick rundown what islam so you
just have a real comprehensive easy to
understand
we believe that islam was there since
day one with the first man adam and
throughout time god almighty out of his
love like it's about love out of his
love and mercy he sent guidance and
every messenger came with the same
message every prophet of messenger came
to the same message thank you that's
what i was trying to make you party
like i'm christian but
god sent every
message
in different religions god almighty sent
messengers and prophets different places
at times and destinations and from there
that message is always the same worship
the creator that heavens and earth along
without associates and obey the
messenger that was sent so at noah's
time you have to obey just like how you
guys say allah to allah
like like how we say all love to jesus
what i've seen over the years talking to
many christians also is because
obviously they don't know that we also
as muslims love and revere jesus as one
of the mightiest messengers sent by god
that he was the messiah over time god
almighty sent message prophecy message
all came to the same message worship one
and only one god and be morally upright
so the messenger that was set during
that time thank you you see how you said
it during that time
every every one
jesus after jesus then we say prophet
muhammed peace and blessings be upon him
thank you my brothers thank you you see
so during jesus's time we would say that
the message was
what that means is there's nothing where
you'd have to proclaim or profess that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator that heavens on earth and
jesus is his messenger yes during moses
worthy worship except the one god
almighty and moses messenger we say
during this time now
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one god and muhammad is his final
messenger right so jesus did pro certain
miracles to prove that he was indeed a
messenger sent by god you see how you
asked me yeah have i ever read the quran
right it's the living miracle that we
have today
what's the last message in the quran
prophet muhammad peace and blessings
yes thank you my brother you know
malcolm when he came back
from hutch you know when he's standing
come over here he's standing like sure
he's standing next to the white to the
black that's how malcolm's standing and
what and what he said he said he said
before i went to the nation
yes or the holy land
i never knew
i had brothers that was white look at
that asian
black
or air right yes
because his mind was
washed with anybody that had pale skin
and blue eyes or blond hair or look like
a white man was an enemy but they're not
your enemies no you your own enemy
because guess what if you don't believe
in the lord
you make yourself the enemy people can
do stuff
but
you can forgive them
forgiveness is the biggest thing in this
world and i wish a lot of people would
understand that are you feminists
forget people